hour
this wasn't just a margin support of the
right to an abortion this was
specifically focused on mobilizing
turnout for the upcoming midterm
elections to defeat those who support
the rolling back of female reproductive
Health Care with the chance our power
our vote we know that this is a very
anti-democratic
um you know initiative we know that this
is something that the American people do
not support and so we're here to make
sure that folks have the opportunity to
make their voices heard and then make
their votes heard on November 8th
since the Supreme Court overturned the
constitutional right to an abortion in
June the issue has become a focus of
midterm races across the country for the
U.S Congress State governorships and
State legislatures
it's detracted from what had been seen
as a potentially winning platform for
the Republicans to focus on the economy
crime and Joe Biden's personal
unpopularity as president the polls
suggests those issues do still dominate
voters concerns but the Democrats sent a
big opportunity to mobilize even their
most disillusioned of Voters a handful
of counter protesters showed up at the
rally too who argued that the whole
debate was based on a misunderstanding
there is no state of abortion in either
direction in the U.S Constitution and so
they returned the issue to the states
and so we think it's a lot of
misinformation
but that's precisely why abortion rights
activists say it's so important to get
out the vote locally since June
Republican govern state after State have
restricted access to abortions in
addition Joe Biden says Congress could
codify the right to an abortion into
federal law if the Democrats had a few
more votes in Congress although that's a
promise multiple democratic presidents
have not kept in the past not long ago
it seemed like a real possibility that
the Democrats would be completely wiped
out in these midterms because of
inflation and Joe Biden's low popularity
ratings but now the Democrats hope that
Republican overreach on abortion will
lead the Democratic base and swing
voters to vote Democrat despite their
disappointment in what they've achieved
since taking control of Congress and the
presidency
she abrahamsi Al Jazeera Washington